نيران الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا مشتعله
منذ اكثر من عام ليطرح تساؤل جديد حول
مستقبلها هل تكون القبعات الزرق من يبرد
نيران الحرب ام من يؤججها طرح جديد على
طاوله النقاش الاوروبيه اقترحوا ارسال
قوات حفظ سلام اوروبيه الى اوكرانيا كما
اعلنت المجر نحن قريبون من مناقشه مساله
مقبوله وشرعيه مع القاده الاوروبيين بشان
امكانيه ارسال الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قوات حفظ سلام الى اوكرانيا
طرح قد يغير التقسيم الجغرافيه لاوكرانيا
ففي حال انتشار قوات حفظ السلام في
المناطق الفاصله بين سيطره القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه قد تصبح السيطره
الروسيه شرعيه امر واقع على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه مع الزمن
لكن التصريحات الروسيه تعكس غير ذلك
فالكريم لن يعتبر نشره تلك القوات امرا
خطيرا على حد تعبيره اذا كانت النقاشات
التي دارت في الاتحاد الاوروبي حول ارسال
قوات حفظ سلام الى اوكرانيا جديه بالفعل
فهي تحمل خطرا كبيرا
خطه لا يبدو لها افق واضح خاصه مع تصريحات
جوزيف بوريل مسؤول خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي اكد انهم سيفعلون ما يلزم
لدعم انتصار كييف لكن مع العقيده الروسيه
الجديده فان التصعيد يبقى سيد الموقف اذا
عمر العربيه